To invalidate something, it has to
happen before it can be invalidated.
Right? This is not considered.
It is considered men.
It's considered not to be of the
invalidators of wudoo, but
of the inhibitors of wudoo. It stops
wudoo from even happening in the first
place.
An invalidator of wudoo is passing
gas using the restroom. Woo was had and
then it was invalidated.
An inhibitor
of wudoo is something that prevents it
from even being valid in the first
place. Now why is that? Well, we
understand
that nothing of what Allah commanded be
washed can be left out.
And part of that is the nails. The
nails. This part of the nail, it's not
part of our flesh, right? But the nail
is part of our hand. And that is the
part of the fingers which is obligated
to be washed. Now if a person has paint
on any part of his hands or arms or on
his fingernails or her fingernails
and this will prevent the water from
reaching the fingernail
woo cannot be had and this is why
it is such a major thing. It's not a
small thing. And this is something that
oftent times
women compromise over. You know,
I've I've met plenty of sisters that
choose this to compromise their salah
and woo over
because they believe that it is a
beautifification.
Sure. to an extent it's a
Although I will tell you this,
most
much if not most
of what women do
of so-called beautifification
men don't necessarily find attractive
in the first place.
Most much if not most of the
beautifification is not for the sake of
her husband. It's for the sake of her
self-esteem
or a lot of times for the sake of
competition with other women.
So tell me, when have you ever heard a
man say,
"This woman is very beautiful. If only
she had longer eyelashes." When did you
ever hear that? You're men.
I'm a man.
When did you even ever think that this
this woman, she's almost perfect? It's
just her eyelashes are just a touch too
short. I wish she had eyelashes so long
that it looked tarantulas were
crawling out of her skull. That's what I
wish. Then she'd be perfect. When did
you ever hear this or even think it to
yourself,
right? When
have you ever thought to yourself or
heard another man
compliment a woman's nail polish? even
to yourself, say, "Wow, that nail polish
is fantastic." Or,
"Her nails would look a lot better if
they were much longer, if they look
like,
you know, something out of an X-Men
comic book." Method,
or she'd be great if she just had
much bigger lips. So big that it gives
me a feeling of uncanny valley. Like
none of this is something
that men desire spec specifically a
husband. If a husband desires these
kinds of things, it's usually because he
has been infected by
the
popular illnesses going around amongst
disbelievers amongst
is that nails are trimmed at least once
every 40 days.
let alone taking nails that don't belong
to you, made out of plastic or whatever
else, and gluing them onto your actual
nails. This is not the
appeal of a believing woman.
And men,
you know, they do things as well. Not
necessarily because women this or
because their wives find this impressive
or
appealing, but because they are
competing with other men.
for instance, when has a woman,
a wife, ever sat and thought to herself,
I would love my husband to wear super
skinny tight jeans. jeans so tight they
look they were picked out of the
women's section. That's what I want my
husband to wear. When has a woman ever
said this?
When has a woman ever said, "I want my
husband to wear a shirt so tight that he
can barely breathe."
Or, "I want my husband to wear capries
or super short shorts or any of these
other things that non-Muslims wear.
These this is not the apparel of the
believing man. This is not the apparel
of believing women. However, women are
far more subject to these types of
pressures.
And that's okay. That's part of a
woman's nature. That's what makes her
malleable and makes a marriage possible.
However,
these are things which
often times are impermissible. A
non-Muslim woman, a woman that doesn't
know who created her, where she came
from, why she exists, what's expected of
her, where she's going. She is swimming
in darknesses stacked on top of each
other. Of course, they're going to glue
other people's hair onto their own hair,
and she's going to glue eyelashes onto
her own eyelashes, and nothing is going
to be good enough that Allah gave her.
These these are the symptoms of someone
who does not believe in Allah in the
last day.
The believer has a completely different
outlook on life. And one of those
outlooks is we beautify what Allah has
given us. And we do not wish for that
which Allah has not given us. That's the
outlook of the believer.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
about
he says do not wish for the things that
Allah has given to some over others in
virtue. Don't wish for it.
This is between the genders and between
people in general. And we've taken a
couple of days ago the only two things
that are worthy of your envy. What are
those two things?
[Arabic recitation]
Allah and knowledge
that is implemented.
Right? Knowledge that is implemented.
Wealth in shorter terms then. and wealth
that is spent for the sake of Allah.
Anything else not worth your envy, not
worth your pining, not worth your
jealousy, not worth your insecurity.
And everyone has insecurities.
But if you hyperfocus on them, they will
only get worse,
right? They will only get worse.
Do you think that these
things the eyelashes that are
latched on to the eyes, this will be and
can act as a preventative of wudoo?
Likewise,
certain types of makeup that are put
onto the skin that have to be taken off
with chemicals, no amount of water will
wash it off. This will prevent a
person's woo.
Right.
And
there are women I know even in
my own you know of family members or
that
will wear the
nail polish will wear these types of
makeup. Her husband tells her don't do
it.
Students of knowledge tell her don't do
it. Her father tells her don't do it.
She prays five times a day. She makes
sure not to miss a prayer but she
refuses to compromise on that. You might
as well pray without wudoo at all.
What's the difference? If a person says
I insist on praying just not with
I'm not going to make wudoo.
This is something that the scholarship
of Islam have all agreed on will inhibit
a person's woo. And the same thing goes
for any part of the body that has been
commanded by Allah to be washed. If
there is something on the skin which
prevents the water from
penetrating to the skin or the nail
or what have you
then it will inhibit wudoo a person's
wudoo cannot be valid or be had.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Feels
we're missing half of our